all right thanks very much thank you for
coming out student for liberty I know I
spoke at one of the first conferences I
know matt has been speaking at these for
a couple of years thank you guys all for
coming out and for giving us on the
stage at the very least some hope for
the future okay so what we're going to
be talking about is the libertarian
moment over or did it never exist Matt
and I in 2008 coined the term the
libertarian moment to describe what we
talked about as a time of increasingly
hyper individualized hyper expanded
choice over virtually every aspect of
our lives we were talking about at the
depths of the financial crisis hopefully
a world in which it was more possible
than ever to live on your own terms
because of Technology because of change
happening in politics globally a
technological innovation and whatnot and
since then the idea of the libertarian
moment captured the public imagination
in 2014 for instance the New York Times
Magazine wrote a cover story has the
libertarian moment finally arrived and
as we all learned and it was on the
heels of Rand Paul's ascendancy he had
been called the most interesting man in
politics by Time magazine and we of
course know what happened to Rand Paul's
candidacy and we were told just starting
almost immediately that Rand Paul and
the libertarian moment never existed
the libertarian moment wasn't really
happening the false rise or the false
rise and fall of Rand Paul what we're
going to talk about tonight is the ways
in which the libertarian t' is or is not
happening and whether or not we're going
there and with george well we're going
to be talking about whether we should be
actually confronting the authoritarian
moment rather than the libertarian
moment and what i want to do just to set
the scene and the mats going to chat for
a bit is a tiny do not adjust your eyes
that's a
a quote that you won't be able to read
but in 2013 Matt and I interviewed
George well for Reason magazine and we
talked about him having written again
this is a few years ago America is
moving in the Libertarians direction not
because they have won an argument but
because government and the sector's it
dominates have made themselves ludicrous
this has open minds to the libertarian
argument and we asked mr. will dr. will
whether or not he still thought that in
2013 and you answered sir yes for
several reasons the first is that I've
lived in Washington now for 44 years and
that's a lot of folly to witness up
close
whatever confidence and optimism I felt
toward the central government when I got
here January 1st 1970 has dissipated at
the hands of the government and second
you said I participate although I'm in
my 70s and too old to learn too much in
the changing technological assumptions
give you an example when I was growing
up and wanted to hear the songs of the
day Bill Haley and the Comets the
platters and all that stuff I would turn
on the radio and hope the disc jockey
would play three or four of the songs I
wanted to hear in the next hour when my
daughter and other children want to hear
songs they just go to the Internet and
have 50,000 at their fingertips so
before we get into trying to convince
you George
that the libertarian moment is still
happening what is your sense of things
are we past the libertarian moment and
have we entered the authoritarian moment
and if so what are the what's the
leading indicator of that well the
leading indicators at the moment the
leading Republican candidate for
president that is the leading candidate
of the party which if there is a party
with a libertarian streak it would be in
let's say we name this man or will he
appear he's like Voldemort yes
by last August he was pledging to have a
new federal police force that that was
on 11 the libertarian moment a new
federal police force charged with
fulfilling his promise to deport 11 and
a half million people in two years
that's about two hundred and twenty five
thousand a month he will need a new
police force for that five six hours ago
he was on Fox network at Fox television
which would cover him eating breakfast
Steve if he would allow it and he said
that he wanted to open up the libel laws
to make it easier to sue people for
writing negative things which is by the
way how I earn my living he in the
debate the night before the man that we
were thinking of giving the nuclear
codes and Lincoln's chair said that his
sister who's a brilliant lawyer we have
his word for this she said she's a judge
actually that she signed the same bill
that Justice Alito signed now we have a
man who was the leading candidate of one
of our two major parties to be President
United States who thinks judges sign
mills in other words this candidate
would flunk an eighth grade civics exam
you think this is going to be the if
this is your libertarian moment you can
look at the other party okay the other
party is has a socialist Ronnie now he's
of course nothing of the sort
time was socialism meant the public
ownership of the means of production
distribution in exchange you can
understand that then they watered it
down a bit particularly the post-war
British socialist to say no socialism is
government ownership of the commanding
heights of the economy heavy industry
steel the railroads commune
Asians of the minds then they watered it
down and this is Bernie Sanders
socialism it is heavy government
regulation of the private sector and
ambitious redistribution of wealth which
is what we've had for at least 40 years
in this country today 60 67 percent of
the federal budget is transfer payments
that is the the sky is dark with money
going back and forth between client
groups served by an administrative state
that exists to do very little else but
regulate the private sector and
distribute income where's the
libertarian moment fit in here
well that is Matt Europe so why don't
you talk a little bit about some of the
signs of good time I'm gonna defend a
headline here we're getting a lot of
guff now that Rand Paul kind of stalled
out at 3% and never went any further and
everyone everyone loves to proclaim
libertarians to be full of Dookie
because we don't fit normally into the
political categories of Democrat
Republican and so they're having a lot
of a sport at our expense as Nick
mentioned this piece that we wrote in
2008 we wrote this 40th anniversary of
Reason magazine which like all great
revolutions started in May of 1968 and
we were we were coming up with various
things to put in this in this issue and
right as we were writing this essay the
financial crisis happened and george w
bush head of the republican party on
september 24th i think it was 2008 stood
in front of the world and said normally
I'm in favor of free-market capitalism
but there was no hope John McCain the
Republican running for president at the
time the roopa Republican who in a way
influencing George will hear very
strongly was someone who believes in
censoring political speech that was the
major achievement of his senatorial
career he suspended his campaign so he
could go back to Washington to support
the bailouts there
no hope in September of 2008 so when we
wrote the headline the libertarian
moment what we were telling people was
like look we know it's super super dark
right now just as it was in many ways as
we lead the essay with in 1971 there's a
lot of dark business happening in
America in 1971 there's wages and price
controls which we can't even fathom
right now was happening in 1971 and yet
if you looked in the right places you
would notice that there were glimmers of
Hope happening and by the end of that
decade there's all kinds of very
interesting very explicitly libertarian
action happening not least of which was
the abolition of the military draft
which is a pretty amazing accomplishment
so I so we said we said this it was it
was to defend it as a moment this moment
isn't a moment to despair we're actually
in an era going forward in which good
things happen so in September 2008 no
one in America was talking about
legalizing recreational marijuana it
wasn't even on anybody's radar going
forward that wasn't happening we heard
earlier today - great congressman I hope
they're here they're probably not Justin
Amash and Thomas Massie very funny very
principled people those people were not
in Congress in September 2008 there was
a popular revolt against large
government known as the Tea Party
movement and that produced people like
Rand Paul produced these things criminal
justice reform which is on the verge of
happening and I hope still can happen
wasn't done anyone's lips in 2008 so
even though we're living in this dark
moment in an authoritarian and scary
moment as George will rightly points out
a lot of very promising great things
happen including things that were
unfathomable to some of us older people
going for years for decades the fact
that guns were recognized now recognized
as the Second Amendment is an individual
right was not something that a lot of
people were thinking about back then so
all of these things have happening and
this is something that I that is worth
thinking about since you are younger
than me
out there and I heard questions earlier
with congressman Amash and Massie of
like well how do you affect change and
these kinds of things a lot of these
changes happened with some politics in
it and some of the changes happen
because people were rooting all around
politics politics is not
major party politics is not the only
game in town to try to make these
changes happen this slide here talks
about something which I want to spend
this into a question for you George
which is that we live in this really
weird moment where in the last 25 years
a historical number of people 1 billion
people have been lifted out of extreme
poverty even the United Nations says
this is because in large part to
globalize reductions in tariffs and
barriers to trade it's an amazing human
accomplishment and yet we are living in
America at a time when Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
increasingly although her heart's not
necessarily in it are running as heavy
protectionist how is it that America in
your judgment
lost the plot about what is literally
the most tremendous story in modern
times which is the liberation of the
individual and the deep poverty is a
ssin around the world by people using
policies that have absolutely nothing to
do with Bernie Sanders one quick time
ago before actually asking the question
when Barack Obama went to Sweden a
couple of years ago three Swedish Social
Democratic trade unions asked to meet
with him in order to tell him please
President Obama this is Sweden this is
Bernie Sanders is Sweden
please President Obama can you make sure
to reduce trade barriers because that's
the best way for trade unions in
Northern Europe to work so why do we
have Americans lost the plot of what
made the prosperity that's helping us
the world I don't think they have I
think the put the political class has
clearly lost it Donald Trump thinks the
way to make America great is to
retaliate against Oreos being made
outside of the country did you watch it
he said that last night yes and he
believes it well as much as he believes
anything it look it is a fact that for
non college educated white males their
wages have been have been stagnant not
yours I'm sure but their earnings have
been stagnant for 40 years you'd be
irritable and you would be weary and you
would be anxious about
immigration and you'd be susceptible to
protectionist arguments too if you felt
that you were treading water and making
no progress that saying I don't think
the American people are that open to
protectionism the last time we went
through one of these was 1980 when John
Conway running against Ronald Reagan
decided that he would take a stake out
of protectionist position he won one
delegate for all his some woman from
Arkansas for his his efforts in 1984 I
believe it was it was an 88 Gephardt
decided to be a protectionist and he got
nowhere I think the American people
understand this I mean Donald Trump is
waging war on China which is to say he's
waging war on Walmart which is the
biggest importer of Chinese goods and is
by the way with 1.4 million employees
our largest private sector employers
where a lot of Donald Trump voters or
supporters presumably shop so that
there's a kind of madness in the air but
I don't think the American people are
really swept up in it well why is it
happening why is it expressing itself
politically is it just that stagnant the
last 15 years have been lousy for
private sector job growth for everybody
and the aforementioned 40 years of
badness for my fellow college dropouts I
think so there's nothing wrong with this
country in a major way that can't be
cured by the difference between 3% and
2% growth I think the political class
believes that the difference between 2%
and 3% is 1% it is of course 50% and
that makes an enormous difference any
institution in this country anyone on
the board of a school a museum with
Symphony Orchestra that has an endowment
knows that at three or three and a half
percent growth America is happy because
we don't have the politics of allocating
scarcity about which our institutions
are not very good but at 2% growth
everyone is sour elbows are thrown
and government becomes a matter of
carving with increasingly sharp elbows
and nastiness a stagnant pie you I think
George you were saying or implying if
not outright saying that Donald Trump is
an effect of the breakdown of the way
the political class or the way the
economy is working he's not the cause of
it or his people say well we're mad
because nothing's getting done in
Washington then you say what do you want
to get done and you get a blank stare
right I think it's entertainment I think
there's been a kind of rage machine
cranked up in this country and people
get addicted to rage and the kind of
whatever part of the brain is is engaged
for that we'll call it the Trump Imam
well before before there was Trump in
politics it was Bill O'Reilly in
journalism and it's the kind of constant
sense of indignation we're not quite
clear about what but indignation becomes
its own pleasure I cannot disagree
greatness story and I hear that you are
trashing your own partial employer
aren't you with Fox News
yes so here is one of the things that I
want that maddening are booked a
declaration of independence which grew
out of the libertarian moment I said one
of the things that we were looking at
was that over the past 40 years or so
the number of people who are willing to
tell random strangers on the phone that
they belong to either the Republican or
the Democratic Party has been shrinking
and we're not just belonging to a party
started mob it's it's general
affiliation like do you feel like a
Democrat you feel like a Republican do
you identify with one of these parties
not necessarily if you're registered
with them or if you vote and one of the
things that is fascinating that Gallup
does a couple of polls once a year and
in their governance poll one of the
things that they found recently is that
there is a record recent record low
number of people who call themselves
Democrats it's that 29% it had been in
the high 30s just a few decades ago
Republicans are at 26% which is one
point up from from their lowest point
also over that same
period and you can see this in the chart
independence people who are either
unaffiliated or say I'm independent has
been growing people who are willing to
talk about being a member of the GOP or
the deaf nor the Democratic Party have
been failing on top of that they also do
a thing where they use two questions to
key in on people's perspective about the
role of government and they and from
that they create topologies for
typologies you're either a conservative
or libertarian a liberal or a populist
and they ask these two questions the
first says some people think the
government is trying to do too many
things that should be left to
individuals and businesses others think
the government should do more to solve
our country's problems which comes
closer to your view so that's one
question the other is some people think
the government should promote
traditional values in our society others
think that the government should not
favor any particular set of values which
comes closer to your view and if you
look on the the chart here for the first
time lip the libertarian group which
came in at 27% based on that index is
the highest there's 26% who call
themselves conservatives 23% call
themselves liberals 15% populist and 10%
for any other category that fits into
that so I guess my question then to you
George is where where does the Trump and
in an odd and interesting way the
Sanders anger element where is it coming
from or how does that counter the idea
that government or a strong man is going
to solve all our problems very
authoritarian how does that fit with
some of the developments that Matt was
talking about both in US politics and
globally and then with attitudes that
we're seeing in the American population
where they're leaving the parties and
they seem to be moving towards
libertarianism I think the explanation
is cognitive dissonance that is a fancy
way of saying people hold in their minds
with equal fervor and sincerity flatly
incompatible ideas the American people
have always talked like Jeffersonians
but they have almost invariably wanted
to be governor
by Hamiltonians by a large omnipresent
omnipotent state now Hamilton he's that
rap artist on today I think 42% of
Americans identify his independence
first of all most of them are behavioral
Democrats or behavioral Republicans it's
opposed they may really think their
independence but they're always going to
vote one way or another the Pew Research
Group recently did a survey they gave a
huge sample of Americanism a list of 19
things
lissa do you want spending on them
increased held the same or cut most of
the categories they said please increase
a few they said hold the same the one
thing they said to cut was foreign aid
which is 1% of the federal budget so
limited government with Americans is a
rhetorical position its avowed but not
constraining I'm afraid just wait until
you mean again Donald Trump said in
South Carolina at a town hall he says I
am the only one of the Republican
candidates it won't cut the hell out of
your Social Security of course no one
can even get either party to move on the
chain CPI which would be a miniscule
reduction of the inflation adjustment of
Social Security and everyone
acknowledges it would be more accurate
measure of inflation but no one will go
near that and Social Security of course
is the small problem compared to to
Medicare here we have 10,000 baby
boomers every day becoming eligible for
Social Security and Medicare they vote
they vote increasingly for the
Republican Party which means the
Republican Party is least apt to make a
serious attempt to reform the
entitlements and Donald Trump again
he's no longer unmentionable Donald
Trump's social policy in a few words is
we're gonna take care of everybody
that's a quote that's his view and then
it's gonna be great
it'll be beautiful and be used yeah they
said you never fix will be huge yeah
Matt how do you respond to or where do
you think Trump
what is the interplay then I guess
between that dimension we're going to
take care of everybody but first we're
going to remove 12 million people or 11
and a half million people from the
population and does that actually play
well I think that it's very interesting
when you look at exit polling or
entrance polling in the first primary
states they asked in Iowa New Hampshire
what issues you cared about and the
biggest issue in Iowa I believe was the
size of government no one really was
campaigning on that in Iowa we're
talking about that wasn't driving media
cycles partly because Republicans
control both houses of Congress so that
conflict between Republicans and
Democrats over spending is out the
window
Republicans just put things in omnibuses
tear up the sequester we're no longer
talking about spending anymore the debt
ceiling remember when we had that yeah
we don't have one anymore
no they got rid of that in October it
will have we'll talk about it again in
March 2017 so that political conflict is
gone but yet that thing which animated a
lot of the early Tea Party movement
still a large concern for voters GOP
voters in Iowa and New Hampshire
immigration was not so what does that
tell us about Donald Trump I think and
this is just a postulate here but people
saw immigration for him as a kind of
threshold or a signaling issue not
necessarily that they want to deport
illegal immigrants actually I think
majority of Republicans don't generally
want to yeah actually I've been together
all surveys are subject to you know
phone enus but Gallup has found among
others that a majority of Republicans
favor a path to legalization they are
not citizens I think they favor path to
citizenship even so so and then it's
among the general population that's even
higher so I think what's going
here more is that it is a cultural
situation Donald Trump god bless him god
damn him whatever every single day
several times a day he says things that
you're not supposed to say that the
people who have been talking about
politics who've been making the written
and unwritten rules about what's between
the 35-yard lines and all that kind of
stuff they've all just decided there's a
way that we do this there's more raise
that you have and you can see some
candidates do have those mortgage Marco
Rubio has those morays he has always
declared the winner of every debate by
journalists because they can recognize
themselves in him he talks about policy
with a certain kind of mastery he wants
to bomb a lot of countries journalists
love that um sadly it's true but Donald
Trump breaks those rules he broke the
rule when he said the Mexicans were
rapists he broke the rule when he said
he's gonna deport Syrian refugees who
were already here he's gonna deport the
four million kids but it's not only that
it's also just the use of language you
know repeating someone calling Ted Cruz
a [ __ ] you know every little thing like
that is a rebuke to those who have
looked down on everybody who speaks in a
way that the elites find to be kind of
unwashed and hanky so I think it's more
that so it's not necessarily that this
is rising tide I mean you look about
Republicans had a pretty good election
in November 2014 right they they retook
the Senate that's a kind of a big thing
they had record gains in state houses
and and and everywhere.i Democrats have
no bench because of this did they do
that because of trumpism
this may be one Trump --is-- politician
in this country the the governor of
Maine right LePage Lapage whatever his
name is he's kind of this crazy
character like Rob Ford up in Toronto it
wasn't because of trumpism so so I think
it's because he broke through those
thresholds and people respond to that
culturally yeah he's saying stuff that's
wrong and that I personally disagree
with people will tell you and but he's
saying it and he has the the Hutt's but
to say that that is more important than
the actual content of his policies i and
george do you think if we go back
actually to the you know party
identification and recognizing that
there's limits to this data is are we in
a place where if Trump proceeds to the
nomination of the Republican Party that
the Republican parties you know they
become the Whigs of their day where and
they came out of the Whigs which
disappeared before the civil war I mean
can the can the Republican Party
withstand Trump actually being their
standard-bearer no well they'll still be
a husk of the Republican Party but there
would be I think a third party candidacy
if it's still possible at that point to
get on enough ballots and the
sore loser laws would preclude some of
these candidates from holding the banner
for that party and furthermore if he is
the nominee this will be the first
election in a very long time when there
was no one remotely conservative at the
top of the ticket should he run he will
run I think to the left of Hillary
Clinton because he'll be after the
Bernie Sanders about and he'll get a
fair amount of it and he'll be running
against one of the most unlike
candidates the Democrats have put
forward ever
and therefore it's conceivable he would
be elected now are elected he would run
presumably for re-election in 2020 which
would mean that it would be at least
until 2024 that there would be a
conservative choice for president how
are you defining conservative in that
because an issue-by-issue Trump is you
know he says he's anti-abortion which is
a big issue he's super anti-immigrant
National Review now says that your
attitude on immigration is the key issue
for conservatives he talks about bombing
foreign countries very identified with
conservative foreign policy in the 21st
century how is Trump not conservative
he's an authoritarian he believes in an
inordinately have today is not big
enough and that particularly the
concentration of power not just in
Washington but Washington power in the
executive branch has not gone far enough
conservatism it seems to me as in the
article one project that Mike Lee and
others are fostering is congressional
supremacy it is to tame the executive
power particularly the prerogatives the
royal prerogative that is crept back
into our life from George the third now
it's with George the third or George W
all three okay and it's free markets
there's no free market dimension to
Donald Trump who's if we ever see his
beautiful his words his beautiful tax
returns we're going to see that he is a
crony capitalist through and through but
is that and can I just a so on the
free-market issue the conservative
Republicans when you look at somebody
like Ted Cruz Marco Rubio I'm not sure
about Ted Cruz's against the
trans-pacific partnership which is more
or less the inheritor of NAFTA you can
you know there are questions about it
and whatnot but it's clearly a free
trade agreement and it seems the
Republican Party is against that as long
as as President Obama is going together
that is part of it and yeah they're
terrible I'd said there's there's
problems with TPP I'm not but still it's
a free trade agreement in a way that is
recognizable the way these things got
trust and and the crews who do his great
credit became the first person in modern
history to run against the ethanol
industry in Iowa and carried Iowa knows
better than this would have to know
better it's part of the depressing
response of the political class to the
needs of the nominating season well if
we can go back to the slides for a
second you know I had quite honestly
expected this conversation to go
differently and I thought we were going
to be talking about how libertarian it
is and you know come on kids catch a
rocket ride here
so if you can put the and I had put
together three recent issues of Reason
magazine I'm sorry can you put those
slides back up thank you so after
talking about how great now how with
libertarian everything was getting you
know free ponies and all of that kind of
stuff we were going to
talk about threats to the libertarian
moment but I think instead what we're
seeing are the people who are vying for
the authoritarian moment here well let
me try and cheer you up
Roy Rand Paul did the country and the
Republican Party a favor by making
foreign policy heterodoxy possible
within the Republican Party and to cause
a rethinking that is you can see it in
in Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is not quite as
bellicose as as Marco Rubio Rand Paul's
campaign died the day the ISIS released
the first beheading video it was over
because he was going to stake out a
rethinking that we much need because of
Libya particularly which do you think
that it it died because he did not
double down on his position or explain
why even if freelance journalists are
being killed we should not invade people
or chess that was over people you most
lindsey graham's the only guy I know who
really wants to invade who has had the
courage of his convictions know it died
because people didn't want to hear that
anymore because instantly national
security went above all other issues
there are there are good signs underway
for example your colleague Damon root
who's written a wonderful book overruled
I believe is the title everyone here
ought to read it the the most
interesting argument in American
governance today is not between
Republicans or Democrats it is between
conservatives using the term inclusively
here who believe that we need that we
need as conservatives have been saying
for years a deferential judiciary
passive and and deferential to the works
of the majoritarian branches of
government oh and on the other hand
those who like Clarke Neely you wrote a
wonderful book of terms of engagement
that he's a lawyer at the yes for
justices Damon rout me others Randy
who argue on the contrary that what we
need is an engaged you dish are'
asserting the fact that the essence of
America is not majority rule it is
Liberty and that it is a dereliction of
judicial duty not to swat down not to
presume that government has a burden of
proof that when it acts it has reason to
act the libertarian premise as I
understand it is that before the
government interferes with the liberty
of the individual or the liberty of two
or more individuals contracting together
voluntarily it ought to have a good
reason and it ought to be able to
demonstrate that to a court which says
you are violating not only the
enumerated rights of the Constitution
but those unenumerated rights affirmed
in the ninth amendment and therefore we
need a more robust judiciary what are
the two decisions that we most enjoy in
the 21st century so far from the supreme
what one with one that we hated the most
was kylo wherein the court behaved the
way conservatives have urged the court
to behave which is deferential to an
elected body which in this case was the
city government of New London
Connecticut when it stole the property
of the people in that neighborhood the
other good decision the good decision we
like most of citizens united wherein the
court overturned for our decisions and
overturned certain clear principles
enunciated by that by the elected
officials around the country by saying
that when Americans band together in
corporate form they do not for the
purpose of advocacy they do not forfeit
their First Amendment rights we need a
more engaged judiciary this is and this
is a rising intellectual force in this
country with a libertarian purpose and
libertarian consequences so on the one
hand in foreign policy we now have its
discussable that you can say Libya was a
mistake
second only to
of Iraq and perhaps American yes
certainly in recent American history
domestically there is an understanding
that where our first duty is not to
preserve majority rule which is just
another way of saying might makes right
but indeed to protect the enumerated and
unenumerated rights which is what
America is about in that sense we have a
new vocabulary a new intellectual
movement and that's why if I could say
parenthetically why I think it's a shame
we're not going to have a hearings and a
floor vote and a full debate on an Obama
nomination a because that would educate
the country as to what the issues are in
be it would force the Republicans to
decide what they think most of them have
no clue on this subject so we are just
about out of time what I wanted to just
as a final moment Matt could you talk
George talked about some of the ways to
break the authoritarian tendency in
American politics that's rising through
the judiciary when you look at you know
three three major candidates Trump
Hillary Clinton Bernie Sanders in
different ways all have authoritarian
tendencies they're majoritarian or
they're authoritarian in in the way that
Trump where where do you look for a
moment of optimism my I mean granted I'm
in the business of arguing and of not
supporting politicians but I find that
it's it's very valuable especially this
moment where there's no one to really
think about rooting for in any tangible
way is just okay great let's talk about
every single one of these issues let's
talk about a $15 minimum wage imposing
that in Columbus Ohio in addition to
Seattle Washington and how absolutely
utterly bonkers
that is from a let's it's a this is this
election is a great chance to talk about
Keela versus New London which Donald
Trump totally supports great decision
why not love it
so it's it to have these kinds of
discussions about what these people
stand for Hillary Clinton has one of the
worst track records on free speech in
the country if not the worst great so
let's talk about that on an individual
base
and also always recognize that political
change happens in many cases outside of
politics not inside of it and taking
some comfort in that thank you we are
we're gonna leave it there thank you
very much for listening to us I want to
thank Matt Welch my recent colleague and
George Will of the Washington Post and
maybe a Fox News on Sunday thank you
thanks so much and remember also I want
to I also want to thank students for
liberty this is a group that is young
and vibrant and you you are the change
not that Obama wanted you to be but
whatever you want the world to be and do
it in politics do it outside of politics
but for God's sakes do it thanks so much